no how old are your kids uh i got a 10
year old daughter and a 12 year old son
oh damn you're in it yeah i got a five
he'll be five in february and a
one-year-old
oh that's adorable man the best two boys
dude it's the best kids are the best and
we just got a pandemic puppy as well i
was never a dog person
just got the dog and there you go a
golden doodle
oh those are she's adorable my brother
sleeps with them you have kids you have
dogs i mean
no dogs i want dogs my girl doesn't want
dogs she doesn't want
dogs are a beast man she doesn't want
the responsibility well you know it's a
lot i will tell you once your kids are a
little bit older kids love them
love them and and if you get like if you
go and get
you know you can do your research a
little bit see which ones are which we
got we got the golden doodle simply
because
uh she's hypoallergenic yeah they don't
shed too they don't shed and my daughter
had some allergies and stuff so we're
like all right you know what let's let's
go ahead and do it a dog in the pandemic
though it's probably the best time to do
it because you don't have to leave it at
home
well that's with it 24 7. yeah i was
nervous just like your
your lady is that because i've never had
a dog and i was like oh my god
ever never we had a dog once for two
days yeah
that's right no because you don't count
from an immigrant background yeah so
when i would tell my dad i want a dog i
want a dog he didn't understand what
that meant and like
in the iranian culture listen a lot of
immigrants don't
like the dogs aren't big in a lot of
immigrant cultures yeah like in iran
dogs are known to be like they say
nadjes which means
um like dirty like you're not supposed
to like there's wild dogs running
streets
yeah of course in the past 40 years i'm
sure it's changed a lot but when i was a
kid that's how it was
and so when i'd be like i want a dog i
wanna die my dad's like no no and then
finally when i was i don't know how old
i was but
he went to his friend who had two dogs
that had grown up together
and he's like give me your give me one
of those dogs this shows you the
mentality of like
one of those yeah the macho man
immigrant mentality
where there's no like let me do the
research find out if it's okay to
separate a brain
yeah let me have one for my son and the
other guy's like sure take him
his dog came bro he was with us for 48
hours he was the most depressed dog
he wanted to go home he get me out of
here
he wanted no parker where'd you find
this dog let's go
yeah so so that was um that's all i had
and then so this time around and my wife
and kids were like looking at golden
doodles labradoodles all that
and it's funny because like you just
said i kept saying i was like i don't
know guys i don't know
finally we were sitting there one time
in just front of the tv and she's all
over the instagram doodle pages
and she's like hey there's a dog
available she would get him get her and
i was like
i don't know if it's the right time
she's like you always say it's not the
right time
and then i was like why are you asking
me when you already know the answer
and we went and got her and man it's the
sweetest thing in the world you love it
i love this dog man she's so dope are
you kids in school
my kids are doing the zoom school oh
nothing worse these poor kids
i feel so bad for them but i will tell
you they've been thriving under it and
really yeah both of my kids first of all
they're in private schools that have
done a great job of handling it i can't
believe your private school is not open
well no they're they're they're staying
you know they they go by all the
guidelines and all that stuff
and and i've run into friends of mine
who are like yeah my my kids in public
school and
the teacher shows up for one hour a week
and then i got to teach the rest of the
week i'm like
different you get what you pay for
no but my kids have done a pretty good
my daughter is constantly like
so we got a second floor upstairs all i
hear is like jumping up and down she's
constantly like doing dance contests and
stuff
um just what i don't know what they do
she's just like i just hear her i'm like
our roof's gonna fall like i go i go
she's in a dance school what's she doing
um and then my son is a big dungeons and
dragons guy so he's been running d
d stuff out of his room a little bit uh
nerdy kid
he's actually they can call your son a
nerd yeah
he's actually a really good athlete yeah
but chooses be honest with you yeah i
i love you don't even understand dude
this this hit me one time when i was
doing shows at the san jose improv
i'm walking around with with my friends
and we go on the campus of san jose
state
university and they happen to have a
robotics competition where these
these kids have built robots and the
whole game of the robot game is like
there's a ball
and these guys with their robots are all
nerdy they're like got their robots and
the robots picking up the ball and
running it and throwing it into the
net and these kids you know and and then
we walk out and we happen to overhear
some conversations and these kids are
like
high school kids 16 you know 15 16 and
they're all like yeah you know i said i
thought that they
you know i thought the the the mechanism
that we had going was
quite appropriate right i think and i
overheard them and i turn to my friends
and go oh my god lord let my kids be
like these kids
like they're not somewhere hanging out
at 7-eleven asking for some dude to be
like hey can you buy me some beer
which is the kind of [ __ ] we were doing
me too yeah i'm dude i was all for it so
as much as like
what you just said might you know but
you know both kids are
somewhat you know they're athletic but
i'm leaning and no nerds around the
world
i'm leaning into that i want that little
elon musk i want that little jeff bezos
i want the kid that i don't have to
because you think about yourself like
it's a miracle
that some of us when you start talking
to you about like your your
your youth it's a miracle that we're
still here nuts but the world's
different
too though but we did stupid [ __ ] like
we were like 16 years old i remember
there was a
volkswagen fox which is like a jetta but
uh like a jetta on a diet it's like yeah
super skinny the front's more narrow
small like you could
like you could probably pick up the the
volkswagen fox this
no that's a newer one no no yeah that
one right there that one right there
that one the fox see that thing you see
how small
yeah so that's the 1990 that's about the
car we had
my friend had that car and look it's a
and i think it was very it was probably
this one it's like
you got you got a two-seat you know
two-door and then so
i remember specifically six of us in
that car
coming home from a party in uh uh on
like in the back woods of marin county
where you go like to like
stinson beach and mir mir beach and
stuff great it's all windy roads
two lane and i'm pretty sure the guy
driving it had been drinking too
y'all speed but we got the music blaring
and we're in the back
every turn we're like yeah living
stupid stupid stupid and lucky to be
here and you want you want your kid in
his basement playing dungeons and
dresses i want
my kid being like dad i got a dungeon
i couldn't see this robot you don't even
know bro i sometimes when he talks to me
i don't even know what he's talking
about he's like you know i'm i'm the
dm i go dm what's that like the direct
message someone no i'm a dungeon master
you're loving it is dungeon and dragons
big again
dude it's huge it's not been big bro oh
it's it's back in the major by the way
one of my neighbors down the street and
it's been announced his name is jonathan
goldstein he's the he and john daly they
are the um
they wrote and directed game night and
the new vacation these guys have done a
lot of stuff
they have written and will be directing
a dungeons and dragons movie with chris
pine
oh wow because there was one they did
and
it went really bad right they did it no
this is this is like a big this one's a
big deal
so it's coming up and and um and it is
it's huge
and like guys like um i'll tell you
who's doing it is uh
vin vin diesel plays dungeons and
dragons um yeah
we love it our boy uh uh uh so who was
sophia vergara's husband what's his name
again oh
joe joe yeah no no
yeah yeah he's a big d i mean these d is
back there he is
manginello he's a great guy um he was it
was actually interesting
he was on colbert and i i i'm a fan of
joe's and i'm a fan of stephen colbert's
and i tried to watch it because i was
like it's gonna be it's gonna be
interesting
they started talking d i had no idea
there it is yeah there it is look at him
yeah he's a stud yeah yeah so
all of that there's a geeks out over
dungeons right yeah so it's back
and as a father and i don't know how you
think but as a father i actually
because my parents began being immigrant
parents they were like
i looked at you guys i look at the asian
history you're not talking about right
that's a fair guess what kind of what
kind of what's your background uh
vietnamese vietnamese
what's your background korea korea okay
you know what somebody yeah immigrant
parents do not want
comedian right now they want lawyer
doctor engineer 100
we came all the way from another country
get your ass over to get your education
and i want to be able to say my son the
doctor my daughter the doctor i want to
be able to say we talked about it many
times on the show too dude so that's
part of it right
so they pushed me in such a direction
now brendan how old were you when you
started doing stand-up
uh what am i 37 so i've been
almost six years so 31 so you start even
later than me how old were you when you
started
i was what three years ago okay
seven twenty seven and a half three
twenty three years so i started 26
and that's late right that's late i like
it i look at guys like like i remember
hearing dane coke talk about 17.
chappelle 14.
yeah when i was 17 i wanted to do it i
was doing plays in my school
my teachers all said you're good at it
my teachers would i
used to do i was doing a i was doing a
play i think it was junior high school
my parents came to watch it you know
these immigrant parents they show up
they got the suit on first of all
immigrant parents
suit yeah they think it's a [ __ ]
copacabana or something
i'm the fourth lead middle school player
man
they showed up in the suit and then the
director like you know
after the show the director's being nice
and she's talking to my parents he's
like
you know your son has that has the the
it factors it
you can do this and my parents oh thank
you thank you we get in the car my dad's
like that [ __ ] is crazy
everything's just talking
so i mean i was like oh my god so i got
i got
sidetracked for a long time and that's
why it was 26 when i finally did it
so because of that with my kids i tell
them guys if you find a passion
run with it i'm with you a hundred
percent so when i see this kid do dnd
i'm all about it yeah i will tell you
the other day
i had that moment in my head where i was
like i gotta ask him i like what what's
the
end i was like buddy can i just ask you
a question about dnd he's like sure i go
when you do d d like does it is it
exercising your creativity
yeah is it kind of like just passing
times in my mind
i'm hoping he goes yeah dad we created i
go okay and they said he goes he goes
they create the world i go
all right okay so i'm thinking to myself
maybe he'll be like a uh
what is it rr martin or j.r martin the
guy who wrote the the game of thrones
books george
maybe he'll just write that maybe he'll
write game of thrones or something lower
the ring
yeah in my mind that's what i figured
you know yeah
you know yeah that's a long shot but you
know it's tough yeah with
with my kid uh tiger he you know he'll
be five
in february because you know my fight
background sports background so i'll
watch fighting sports
and i'll go dad boom boom pound always
want to fight me get but you're not
gonna do like i know you
enjoy it with your dad but you're not
gonna do this yeah the kids don't grow
up in this house and fight in in the
cage
yeah yeah that's not what that's not how
it is it's an interesting it's an
interesting journey we go through
because
like you just said you want your kid i
mean that's all you want you want you
could just be passionate about whatever
it is
and again when you think about the kind
of stuff you did you worry about your
kid because
oh my god but also you crawl i don't
mean interrupt you but also
like i made some sacrifices and crawl
through some [ __ ] and have ct
so you don't have to do this absolutely
but if you choose to do it then you're
going to do it you know what i'm saying
there's nothing you do
my dad didn't want me to fight my dad
didn't want me to do stand up
if their heart is set on they're going
to do it and you better jump on for the
ride and that's the beauty if you're
lucky enough to have a passion about
something i always tell people i go you
find that passion go for it whatever
that passion because that's when it gets
tricky if they don't
have something they want to do like a
passion that's where they get into drugs
exactly exactly and it's and it's and
it's a you know i think
i always tell i remind comedians we are
very lucky
to have found our passion yes and so
number one if you can find your passion
you're you're part of the elite group of
people in the world who
know what they want to do if you're able
to make a living doing that passion
now you're like boy you know super elite
yeah you know because
and then i run into people a lot of
times who go i don't know like i'm stuck
and i don't know
what to do and i go okay go back to what
you used to do as a child
what did you used to do you used to play
baseball well
um maybe you should go try to see if you
can become a baseball coach for uh for a
little league team or something
find a way back into that thing because
i just feel we get
lost in life a lot of people get lost
you know just bills right
bills and i think you you you pile it
all on yourself because
it's the it's the being afraid
of trying that thing so you do what's
safe you do with safe so for me for the
longest time i kept jabbing
like the idea of i want to do the acting
i want to do the comedy and my mom had
put into me
you can go be a lawyer and then just do
comedy on the side
so that was in the back of my mind so i
was going to i studied political science
undergrad thinking i'm going to be a
lawyer
then my junior hotel was that at
berkeley yeah
then uh then my junior year i went to
italy to study abroad
and there was a professor i loved what
he was doing i go maybe i'll be a
professor and i go that's a good
compromise
because that'll combine like standing in
front of a crowd and speaking but also
my parents can
you know brag you know yeah it's a
formidable job right
and when i came back my mom was freaking
out no you got to be a lawyer and i was
like what's up i thought professor
pretty good she was like no there's no
money for professors i'm like
what do you know yeah my mom was like so
good
good point right and then she's like
you're going to be wearing those jackets
with the elbow patches
jackets the daggers
it's not good not a good look so then
mom said it was awesome so then she um
so then when i and then i
then i got into a phd program for poli
sci and when i dropped out of that
was when i decided to go and pursue this
because
i had that see i had the fear always of
of trying it
because i thought well how does one even
make it in this world i have no idea so
i was good at it i was doing plays on
the side and i was having fun but i had
a job to bring the money in because i
didn't know how you're gonna make money
and i remember talking to this guy um i
was working in an advertising agency
that was my day job at that point
and this guy named joe ryan who is he
was in his 60s at the time
and he goes hey he saw me do a play he
goes you're pretty funny have you
thought about doing this like oh yeah
i've been thinking about it i'm gonna
wait to raise money you know save up
some money and then go for it
and he goes listen man i'm in my 60s
right now and there were some things i
wanted to do in my 20s
and i never did it because it was if you
really have a passion for it you should
go for it
i was 26 that was a light bulb moment
when i realized you live once
you got to live for you do what you want
to do you can't live for your parents
you can't live out of fear
so you know what you guys were saying is
like the people that that
that don't go for their passions i think
a lot of times it's this fear that if
they go for it
like they're going to throw away
everything they have they you know the
the rent or the bills yeah whatever but
but i think too with with stand-up
like and for your parents or even my
parents like it's like oh i want to do
stand-up but there's no
there's no like clear path like like if
you want to be a professor whatever
if you want to make the nfl or whatever
you want to do in that space there's
always a path if i want to make the nfl
i play pop wander and i go high school
if i'm good at that then i get
scholarship play college football then i
get drafted the nfl pretty clear
path yeah stand up yeah it's like
everyone's path is different
here i started here yeah so there's like
no blueprint
but even that like let's go back to the
football thing right so if i'm some guy
who's
you know i mean there was a movie made
about the guy who was visible
was that what it was the the
philadelphia eagles
right uh papali yeah wasn't he like a
teacher or something
he was a teacher yeah he was a teacher
and then he they had open tryouts
yeah so there you go now he also ran a
four four forty well as we could say
it's not listen by the way
it's not like you could be sitting there
going like oh i'm 60 years old and i've
been you know
a couch potato my whole life i'm gonna
go you know play uh quarterback for the
whatever you know the saints yeah but
the fact is
if you have a passion that is something
that like let's say you are 60 years old
and you've been working as an accountant
for
the past 40 years and it's just just
draining your soul
and your passion was football as a kid
maybe you were pretty good
what's to stop you from saying all right
you know what on the weekends i'm gonna
go help
coach a team i'm just gonna just to be
out in that world yeah just to put
yourself around it
right not everyone's gonna be a comedian
that wants to be a comedian but they can
work as managers they can work in the
club
they could do something so that's i
think that's part of it i think people
are afraid
because they feel like what's the if
they're afraid is the unknown
because if you if someone comes and goes
hey i want to stand up like
all right dude go to open mics yeah you
know start there and try and build a
following
big unknown yeah i think you have to
love the journey first
yeah you have to love the journey well
that see that's a lot of people don't
even know
about you got to love the journey i
think that i think that that
one of the other things that guy said to
me joe ryan it was all about like
can you can you live without this you
know you hear a lot of you hear a lot of
actors say that like i think morgan
freeman or maybe with tom hanks or
somebody was like
if you want to get into acting ask
yourself can i live without it if you
say yes
then live without it because there's
gonna be people who can't live yeah
you're not gonna make it how about
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son